so three pieces yeah well really two
pieces and then a question
firstly why is a function right so we
have differentiating this it's not going
to simply be one on why okay because the
fact that they tell you why is really a
function of X means they want to
differentiate with respect to X okay
which is actually what we normally do
okay so let's give this a go shall we
this is the first part of clue
differentiate log of Y okay now if Y is
just a function right we're taking log
of a function
this is chain rule what does it look
like yeah that's right um y - 1 why we
used to say F - Lance right but it's
just labels yeah now just to make it
clear up because you know I try to avoid
using dashes that anything can sembly
just I'm gonna write Y - in its full
form dy DX
although bar just to be obvious all
right right so there's a clue which
turns out to be not very clear
like I don't even have anything even
remotely resembling that at least not
yet so what do I do
do you direction would you go in
they're giving you this clear I've given
this clear what would you do that okay
so this is actually usually where
questions begin right but there are sort
of expecting you to try and work that
out even this clue right this is a
function and therefore what you do with
this okay now if I want to differentiate
this you've got a problem because it's
not X to the power of a number lots of
power constant so I can't just use the
power rule and it's not a constant to
the power X so I can't just use the
exponential rule right so that's why
this sort of chain rule comes into play
because our clue is in terms of logs
what do you think would be the most
natural first step that's right take a
lot well you got two options
number one it's an index initial
equation so I can rewrite it as a log
equation which I guess would look like
this log base X of Y is equal to X yes
that would be fine okay
and you can get the answer out of this
but in this case it actually adds a
couple of lines for you and we should
know that there's a better direction to
go in a more efficient one because of
the clue they gave us right so even
though this this will get us there
eventually I'm gonna start with this
light and I'm going to take natural log
of both sides okay
that'll give me a natural log okay now I
wonder if the young I wonder if the cogs
are turning can you see why I taken that
for walk here is a good idea sort of
starts to head in the direction of
solving this will be an insoluble
problem okay
because this here I can manipulate right
I can I can get that troublesome power
out of the power how do I do that yeah
this is this can become the coefficient
so remember your log laws right these
are the exactly the kinds of questions
that I appear because they'll still test
if you remember your log laws right we
spent up on top so that's X log X and
this is y and now you can see again the
clue comes in I want to get the
derivative of Y this is actually it's
kind of like implicit isn't it right if
I differentiate the left hand side I'm
gonna get this I already know that
like that output DUI on the X all over
why you different here the right hand
side and that's a product right product
so vu - plus u v - V is log X you - is
just one U is X and P - is whatever X so
X does whatever enters just just a
woman's there we wanted the derivative
of X to the X right
so I want to make P 1 DX the subject so
I guess I all that have to do is put
that Y across but before I write that I
know what Y is I actually introduced it
right so therefore I'm going to get rid
of all the wires and say do you want the
X is X to the X okay so you see then
give you all kinds of questions like
weird ones that you're not expected to
know if they give you the right kind of
clue in the first place okay